how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have to talk about something that is
really huge that happened last night
last night the president of Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige did and asked me
anything on reddit they advertised to
ask me anything and it was Kevin feige's
official confirmed reddit and last night
on reddit he answered a bunch of
questions for about an hour and a half
including mentioning that some of his
favorite characters who he did not name
are coming to the MCU very soon but
perhaps the biggest question that he
answered yesterday involved the Mandarin
and the ten rings and now I'm not
talking about the Mandarin from Iron Man
3 I'm talking about the real Mandarin so
I'll break down the question the answer
and what it means for the future of the
MCU in this video but first do not
forget about my giveaway if you're new
be sure to subscribe to my channel at
the 400,000 subscriber mark I will be
picking three winners and each will be
able to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection so as I
mentioned Kevin Feige answered a lot of
questions yesterday on reddit but one of
the questions that he answered that has
everybody freaking out was about the 10
rings and the Mandarin but not about
that fake Mandarin that we got an Iron
Man 3 the real Mandarin one Reddit user
asked Kevin Feige without going into
details about developing projects are
there any plans to incorporate the 10
rings from the first Iron Man or the
real Mandarin teased in all hail to King
in the future and his answer to this
question was yes and again the question
was very specific about the real
Mandarin not the fake one that we got in
Iron Man 3 the 10 rings were teased in
the very first Iron Man and then we got
the Mandarin in Iron Man 3 but so many
fans were disappointed with how the
Mandarin was betrayed in Iron Man 3 that
Marvel kind of fixed the cannon Marvel
came out with an official one-shot short
film that said that Mandarin in Iron Man
3 was not the real Mandarin and that the
real Mandarin was out there and he is
not happy that he was impersonated so
the real Mandarin and the 10 rings have
been teased in the MCU and according to
Kevin Feige there are plans to
incorporate both of them back into the
MCU
but now of course this also raises the
question is there going to be a new Iron
Man Tony Stark is dead he's not coming
back
iron man but it doesn't mean that we're
not going to get a new iron man in the
MCU this is something that has actually
already been teased in the MCU in the
spider-man far from home trailer you
gonna be a next Iron Man now well no I
don't have time I'm too busy doing your
jobs
the world needs Next Iron Man so it does
seem like Marvel does in fact have plans
for there to be a new Iron Man in the
MCU and not to mention the Mandarin is
the arch enemy of Iron Man
they are super connected in the comics
hence why they put the tin rings in the
first iron man and the fake Mandarin in
Iron Man 3 many people cannot imagine a
Mandarin in the MC without an Iron Man
to take him on now of course that
doesn't mean that the Mandarin cannot
come into the MCU without an Iron Man
because he certainly can but the
Mandarin is known for being Iron Man's
archenemy and the path in the MCU has
been paved for a new Iron Man to enter
such as Harley Kiner who we saw at the
end of Avengers in game at Tony Stark's
funeral and who knows maybe even little
Morgan start could eventually one day
take on the Iron Man mantle although she
would probably be a version of Iron
Heart instead now the Mandarin is a
villain who has gone up against many
different heroes in the comics so it
wouldn't be that hard to introduce him
in another movie in fact it's already
been pretty heavily speculated that the
Mandarin could appear in shang-chi
replacing the characters Zhang's ooh
but of course this is just speculation
for now and many people have already
stated that they cannot imagine the
Mandarin without Iron Man and since
Kevin Feige has confirmed that Marvel
does in fact have plans to reintroduce
the ten rings and the real Mandarin into
the MCU does this mean that we're going
to be getting a new Iron Man many people
can't handle and aren't ready for a new
Iron Man to enter into the MCU
especially because in Avengers in game
we saw our beloved Tony Stark die but
nevertheless it would be odd to see the
Mandarin without Iron Man especially
because the tin rings and Mandarin have
already been introduced in the Iron Man
movies but let me know your thoughts on
this and the comments down below are you
excited for the Mandarin the real
Mandarin and the ten rings to return to
the MCU and do you think we'll be
getting a new Iron Man let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection be sure to hit
the thumbs up button if you
enjoyed this video and be sure to let me
know what you thought of it and of
course as always thank you all so much
for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]